-All eyes are on the Manhattan
grand jury
as we await a possible
indictment of Donald Trump
which would make him the first
president in American history
to face criminal charges.
Trump's allies
in the right-wing media
have been in hysterics
over the news,
and Trump himself used
a rally this weekend
to attack the district attorney
investigating him.
Trump also warned that if he's
arrested,
there will be
"death and destruction,"
which is, to use the words
of George Washington,
not cool, dude!
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Okay, so, we were just on hiatus
for a week,
and the whole time,
I was stressed out
because when news breaks
while I'm on vacation,
no one else in my life
will listen to me.
My kids are the age where
if it's not about "Paw Patrol,"
they don't want
to [bleep] hear it.
This show is my main,
my only outlet.
When we're on break,
my only other option
for conversations about the news
is to call one of those
phone sex hotlines
and tell them,
"No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I just want to talk about Trump
getting arrested."
[ Laughter ]
And then when it comes time
to pay for the phone sex line,
I use a check from
the appropriate bank account
because I don't want to end up
like Donald Trump.
Normally, hiatus is supposed
to be a vacation from the news,
but I spent the entire week
scrolling on my phone
waiting to see a picture
of Trump getting hauled
out of Mar-a-Lago in handcuffs,
mainly because I think
his arms are too inflexible
to reach that far
behind his back.
[ Laughter ]
That's why he always stands with
them straight down at his sides
like a dollar-store G.I. Joe.
It would be super funny
to watch the cops
try to get the cuffs on him.
"Alright, sir.
Put your hands
behind your head."
[As Trump] "Sorry, fellas,
they only go forward
and out like this.
This is the best
I can do for you."
[Normal voice]
They're gonna have...
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're gonna have to get him
a pair of Slinky handcuffs
he can wear
while he's yelling at reporters.
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] It's fun for a girl
and a boy!
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
But here we are.
We're back, and once again,
we're all on Trump
indictment watch.
It could happen
at any moment,
or knowing Trump's luck,
maybe never.
Somehow, Trump always escapes
accountability.
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised
if Merrick Garland
just put himself in jail.
Merrick!
Merrick, why?!
"I don't know, it just...
It just seemed easier."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the funniest
and worst timing
for Trump to be indicted
is between when we tape
this show in the afternoon
and when we air at 12:37
or whatever ungodly hour it is.
[ Laughter ]
If that happens, that means
you're living in a very
different world than I am.
How does it feel?
Is it satisfying?
Or do you just feel empty?
I'm worried
I'm gonna feel empty.
Anyway...
[ Laughter ]
The grand jury
is still doing its work.
In fact, they met
once again today.
As far as we know
as of this taping,
a Trump indictment
has not happened yet,
but could come at any day now.
-A grand jury is expected
to reconvene
in Lower Manhattan
this morning
on potential charges against
former President Donald Trump.
-The grand jury here
is investigating
former President Trump
and the hush-money payments
that were made
to Stormy Daniels.
That grand jury
is set to meet again today.
What remains unclear
as of this morning
is if and when they may vote
on what would be
a historic indictment.
-It's possible, we're told,
that they may hear
from one witness,
at least one witness.
But all of this is taking place
in secret,
so we don't have a lot of sense
of what exactly is going on
behind the scenes.
You know, this process
is normally secretive.
This is a normal
course of events,
but there's just such a big
spotlight on this
as we wait to see whether
District Attorney Alvin Bragg
will move forward
and ask this grand jury
to indict the former president.
-Look, I'm not a prosecutor,
but how many more witnesses
do they need to hear from?
Are they also interviewing
the groundskeeper
at the golf course where Trump
and Stormy met?
"Uh, yeah, I was reseeding
the grass on the ninth hole
when, uh, Mr. Trump came over,
dropped his ball in the cup,
screamed 'That's a hole-in-one!'
then he winked at me and said,
'Let's keep this
between us, Rusty.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, which I should note,
is not my name.
Then his phone rang
and he said, 'I gotta take this.
It's an adult film star
I'm gonna go have sex with.'"
[ Laughter ]
As far as criminal cases go,
this one seems
pretty open and shut to me.
We have testimony
from Trump's ex-fixer,
who already went to jail
for the same crime.
We have a physical copy
of the check itself,
which we know is Trump's because
it has that signature on it
that looks like he's drawing
on the deck of a fishing trawler
trapped in a hurricane.
[ Laughter ]
"This is what the waves
look like!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump's signature looks
like they did an EKG
while he was having sex
with Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it wouldn't be
that long.
It would probably look
more like this.
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] Not sure
that was worth 130K.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] And then,
of course, we have
that infamous clip of Trump's
own lawyer at the time,
Rudy Giuliani, admitting
to Fox host Sean Hannity
exactly what Trump
is being accused of.
And in case you don't remember,
well, here it is again.
-That money was not
campaign money.
Sorry, I'm giving you a fact
now that you don't know.
It's not campaign money.
No campaign finance violation.
So...
-Because they funneled it
through the law firm?
-Funneled through a law firm
and the president repaid it.
-Oh, I didn't know -- He did?
-Yep.
-There's no
campaign finance law.
-Zero.
-So the president --
-Just like every -- Sean --
-So, this decision
was made by...?
-Everybody -- Everybody was
nervous about this
from the very beginning.
I wasn't.
I knew how much money
Donald Trump
put into that campaign.
I said, "$130,000?
He's gonna do a couple of checks
for $130,000."
When I heard Cohen's
retainer of $35,000
when he was doing no work
for the president.
I said that's
how he's repaying --
that's how he's repaying it,
with a little profit
and a little margin
for paying taxes for Michael.
-Yeah, that's the crime,
ya doink!
[ Laughter ]
He had his fixer
secretly pay hush money
weeks before
a presidential election
to cover up an affair,
and then he repaid the money
and lied about
what it was for.
And hey, maybe Trump doesn't
think that should be illegal,
but it is.
He was president for four years.
He should have
changed the law.
Instead of talking
about his dumb wall
or his fake infrastructure bill
that never came,
he should have walked up
to the podium and said...
[As Trump] When you have
an affair, you should be able
to pay your illicit partner
for their silence
however you see fit.
[ Laughter ]
Which is why today I'm signing
the Paying Off Rights Now Bill,
a.k.a. the PORN Bill.
That happened --
that happened by accident.
It happened by accident.
I came up --
I came up with the name first,
and then they showed me
the acronym.
I was -- I was shocked.
The acronyms
will always get you.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Of course,
the best part of that clip
has always been
Hannity's reaction.
-Funneled through a law firm,
and the president repaid it.
-Oh, I didn't know -- He did?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's how you know
something is actually news,
when a Fox host
[bleep] their pants like that.
Can you imagine Walter Cronkite
reacting to major news that way?
[As Cronkite] We have a bulletin
from our Washington bureau.
The president's lawyer
has just admitted
that he paid hush money...
to an adult film star.
Well, [bleep] me.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Also, again,
I'm no lawyer,
but generally speaking,
if you're using money
for something aboveboard,
you never have to "funnel" it.
[ Laughter ]
If you went to
a charity's website
and it said
"click here to funnel"...
[ Laughter ]
...you probably wouldn't.
Now, just to remind you why that
was such a stunning confession,
it's because Trump
paid hush money
just weeks before
a presidential election
to cover up an affair
and hide it from the electorate,
which allegedly broke
multiple laws.
-There's a potential
misdemeanor crime here
for falsification
of business records.
The thought would be
if they falsely classified
these hush-money payments
as attorney's fees,
that could satisfy
the misdemeanor.
Also, this could become a felony
if they falsified those records
in order to commit
some other second crime.
So, what could that be?
What second crime?
It could be a violation
of campaign finance laws.
-He adds on extra crimes
the way the rest of us
add on guac at Chipotle.
"Yeah, I mean, why not?
I'm already here."
[ Laughter ]
There's a good chance
when he heard the first crime
was a misdemeanor,
his plan to dodge it
was to commit a felony
to distract them.
[As Trump]
They're not gonna care about
falsification of records
when I throw Rudy
out the window.
I am gonna need you
to throw yourself, though, Rudy.
I'd never be able to lift you
with my G.I. Joe arms.
[ Laughter ]
[As Giuliani]
Sure thing, boss!
[Normal voice] By the way,
I've said before,
I feel like it would
definitely be better
to charge him
with other stuff first.
You know, like the coup.
I mean, don't get me wrong.
The hush-money payment
is also against the law,
and he should be
held accountable,
but it'll be a bummer
if this is the only thing
he gets indicted for.
On the other hand,
it's also a bummer
that we have a former president
who's under multiple
criminal investigations.
I honestly don't even know how
many crimes Trump has committed,
but let's just say
it's definitely higher then...
-Zero.
-And again...
[ Laughter ]
It's not like Trump did this
decades ago
and it's just being
dredged up now.
He broke campaign finance laws
and defrauded the electorate
in the final weeks
of a presidential campaign
in order to become
the most powerful man on Earth.
And the crazy thing is,
he probably didn't even have to.
Knowing what we know now
about his loyal fan base,
Trump probably could have
gotten up on a stage
at a rally in October 2016
and said...
[As Trump]
I banged a porn star!
I banged one,
and if you vote for me,
you'll all be banging
porn stars.
Porn Stars For All, I call it.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
Now, Trump, predictably,
has been doing his usual thing
where he panics
and throws a bunch of nonsense
against the wall
just to see what sticks.
For example, at a rally
in Texas this weekend,
he blasted prosecutors for using
his former fixer, Michael Cohen,
who made the payment
to Stormy Daniels,
as a key witness.
-They took the word
of a proven liar...
...a convicted felon
and a disbarred lawyer.
All the same person,
believe it or not.
[ Laughter ]
You wouldn't think
that could go to one person.
It would be three, four, five.
-First of all,
he almost sounds jealous.
[ Laughter ]
Proven liar, convicted felon,
disbarred lawyer --
as they call it,
the Trump Triple Crown.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, he's a convicted felon
because of you.
The lies he told and the
felonies committed were for you.
He got convicted for making
the hush-money payment,
the thing you're
being investigated for.
You don't get to use that
against him now.
Next thing we know,
Trump's gonna start
attacking Mike Pence
for being his vice president.
[As Trump]
You can't trust that guy.
He worked for me,
and I'm a real son of a bitch.
[Normal voice] At the same rally
over the weekend,
Trump also lied
and claimed prosecutors
resigned
from the Manhattan DA's Office
because they opposed
the Trump investigation,
which is not true.
In reality,
prosecutors resigned
because they felt the DA
was not moving forward
with criminal charges
fast enough.
-They even had numerous
prosecutors who resigned
because I was being
treated unfairly.
That made me feel so good
when I heard that.
Think of it, people actually
in a Democrat area,
a Democrat office,
they resigned.
Did you know that?
They resigned.
A lot of them
resigned the office
because they said, "You can't
treat a man like this.
He didn't do anything wrong."
-That is definitely not
what they said.
[ Laughter ]
Trump just makes up
fake dialogue
like a middle school
drama teacher
who couldn't get the rights
to "To Kill a Mockingbird."
Alright, the play
we're gonna be doing today
is an original piece I wrote
called "To Wound a Toucan."
[ Laughter ]
The climactic scene
comes at the end
when a lawyer named Amicus Funk
and his daughter Scoot --
it's very important
we call her Scoot --
[ Laughter ]
...befriend the neighborhood
recluse named Bruce Ripley.
And when the sheriff
confronts old Bruce,
they tell the sheriff, "You
can't treat a man like this.
He didn't do anything wrong!"
Then Bruce pays off a porn star.
[ Laughter ]
It also won't surprise you
to learn that Trump
has been trying to menace
everyone into backing down
by essentially
threatening violence.
On Friday, he warned
that there would be, quote,
"death and destruction"
if he was indicted,
which is dangerous
and unhinged, of course,
but also, I'm not so sure,
because when Trump first claimed
he was about to be arrested
and told his supporters to take
to the streets in his defense,
the turnout was --
well, it was underwhelming.
-Despite Trump's calls
on social media to protest,
demonstrations across New York
barely brought out 100 people,
and crowds dissipated
as the day went on.
-Take a live look behind me
right now.
You can see a handful
of supporters are here
on behalf of former
President Trump.
-I'm sorry,
those aren't protests.
Those are tourists.
It's midtown Manhattan.
I've seen bachelorette parties
larger than that.
And louder than that.
You know, some people
live in this city, ladies!
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, it doesn't
count as a protest
if you're outnumbered
by the Times Square Elmos.
[ Laughter ]
So, we don't know
what's gonna happen,
but I'll tell you one thing
we do know for sure.
The only source of information
we definitely can't trust
is Donald Trump himself.
First, he said he was gonna be
arrested last Tuesday,
which didn't happen.
Now he's apparently claiming
the case has been dropped.
-We got new information
this morning
from our Washington bureau on
the plane with Trump last night.
Asked about the Manhattan
DA's investigation,
he said, "I think they've
already dropped the case.
From what I understand,
I think it's been dropped.
But I believe that if anything
ever happened with the case,
it's a fake case.
It's just a fake case."
-So, in one week,
he went from saying
he's about to be arrested
to telling his supporters
to take to the streets,
threatening death
and destruction,
to saying the case
has been dropped.
He talks about getting arrested
like he's choosing
between chicken and fish
at a wedding.
"I'll have the chick--
No, wait.
I'll have the fi-- Never mind.
I'll have the chicken.
If I have the fish,
there's gonna be some death
and destruction in the bathroom,
if you know what I mean.
You all -- You all knew
exactly what I meant.
I shouldn't have -- Okay.
And of course, it's not just
Trump who's been freaking out,
but his toadies
over on Fox News --
you know, the same network
where all the hosts
were texting behind his back
about how much he sucks.
Well, they spent
the last week
pretending to be mad
about the possibility
that Trump might finally be
held accountable for his crimes.
-They'd better not put
my president in prison.
He represents
74 million Americans,
and if he's the nominee,
you're putting 74 million votes
in prison.
-Settlements like this,
whatever you think of them,
are common,
both among famous people,
celebrities,
and in corporate America.
The result is usually known
as an NDA,
a non-disclosure agreement.
In this case,
you can believe whatever side
you want to believe.
But paying people
not to talk about things,
hush money, is ordinary
in modern America.
-Well, you know, years back,
famously, or infamously,
a well-known
New York judge said
in New York,
you can indict a ham sandwich.
So that's what Alvin Bragg
may be doing.
He may be indicting
a ham sandwich.
-Well, especially if
the ham sandwich is named Trump.
-You know, in every other
parallel universe but this one,
Donald Trump's nickname
is Ham Sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
This is the only timeline
where he made a billion dollars
and got elected president.
Everywhere else in the cosmos,
Trump's walking around Queens
with a broom,
offering to sweep your sidewalk
for loose change
while people mutter,
"Oh, look at that ham sandwich."
[ Laughter ]
"It's just sad."
Again, we have no idea
what's gonna happen.
But if we're gonna call
ourselves a genuine democracy
that actually respects
the rule of law,
then it's obvious
that Trump should be
held accountable for his crimes.
It would be nice if,
in addition to this crime,
he was also held accountable
for the coup attempt
or any of his other crimes.
I don't know how many there are,
but if you ask Rudy,
it's probably
in the ballpark of...
-130,000?
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪